je vais
sortir
[Musique]
c'est complet là dans un quart d'heure
ça va être rempli ils attendent tous
dans le froid dans la pluie les grêlons
ils ont faim ils sont affamés affamés
d'amour affamés de joie de voir tout est
dans la voie c'est complet c'est complet
j'étais tombé sur le téléphone de mon ex
qui parlait avec sa meilleure amie et
allumer en gros je vois le SMS affiché
il y avait écrit attention fait le bon
choix donc je me dis ah ouh là ça sent
mauvais moi je fouille pas d'habitude et
là je me dis ça sent pas bon et je
sentais qu'il était un petit peu distant
en même temps et moi je suis un peu team
parano quand même donc j'ai cliqué sur
la conversation juste la conversation et
là j'ai vu le fameux SMS avec écrit
Chloé je crois que c'était Chloé Héloïse
enfin c'était le nom Héloïse et mieux
que Diane à tous les niveaux
[Rires]